and last but not least we've come to
Best Animated Short Film in 1988 this
award was presented to the great John
Lasseter who has since gone on to change
the world of animation when he helped
create Pixar yes
so technically every nominee in this
category has been given the opportunity
to live up to those standards but no
pressure of course you're the nominees
for best animated short film damange
Sunday Patrick Doyle the Fantastic
Flying books of mr. Morris Lessmore
William Joyce and Brandon Oldenburg la
luna and rico casa rosa a morning stroll
grand orchard and sue goth wildlife
amanda forbus and wendy Toby and the
Oscar goes to fantastic flying books of
mr. Morris Lessmore William Joyce and
Brandon Oldenburg
when asked what the biggest challenge
was in making this film William Joyce
says not giving up they did 375 setups
in five days it nearly killed them all
and still it was the most fun they've
ever had this is the first Academy Award
and nomination for the team
yeah look we're just these two like
swamp rats from Louisiana and this is
incredibly grand we loved the movies we
loved the movies more than anything it's
it's been a part of our lives since we
were both kids it's been a part of our
DNA ever since we were children and it's
made us storytellers and there's guys
there's thousands of men and women
through the whole generation since the
beginning of cinema that have inspired
us and movies that moved us more than we
ever knew you it could be moved and and
it's everything we try to do every day
is to honor those people in those films
and we're just down there in Louisiana
where to keep on trying and going and
thank you - thank you our wives oh thank
you our families especially my kids the
Academy I'm Elizabeth and you guys thank
you
you